so I've said before that when we see
these hypothetical national polls that
have Trump being crushed by everyone
like we did last week they really are a
very limited value in figuring out who's
going to win the electoral college in
2020 and you have many polls right now
saying you know if it was Biden versus
Trump who would you vote for if it was
Bernie versus Trump Warren versus Trump
and every single one of those has Donald
Trump losing last week for example we
had a poll I think it was Biden his
leading Trump by nine
Bernie's leading Trump by seven or eight
Warren's leading Trump by seven or eight
and I said at the time this tells us
very little for a couple different
reasons number one these things
typically tighten and move to the
incumbent meaning a lot of that you when
you look at 52 41 for example that's
only ninety one percent of the vote that
leaves nine percent hanging out there
some will go third party some could
consolidate around the incumbent so if
Trump ends up getting 47 and Biden gets
his 50 Biden will win the popular vote
much like Hillary did but could still
lose the electoral college to Donald
Trump because remember Hillary Clinton
won by three popular vote lost the
electoral college so what I've been
saying for a long time now is we need to
be looking at polling in key states
states that are more likely to tell us
the way that electoral e the election is
going to go Pennsylvania Wisconsin
Michigan North Carolina most most people
have a sense of what those states are
now in those states things are not
looking quite as good for the Democrats
and in particular they aren't looking
great for Elizabeth Warren according to
a recent New York Times poll but today
we're gonna look at a specific case
study there is new polling out of Iowa
io is the first primary state
hypothetical matchups Trump versus
whoever and Trump is winning every
single one now that being said it's not
all bad news and what I am increasingly
fatigued by I'm getting some scandal
fatigue from Trump but I'm really
fatigued by black-white narratives by
corporate media trying to be sensational
I'm actually going to tell you what we
can glean from this and what we can
so we've got a new Emerson College poll
Iowa hypothetical matchups if it's Trump
versus Sanders Trump is +7 if it's Trump
vs. Warren Trump is +7 in Iowa if it's
Trump vs. Biden Trump is +4 and if it's
Trump vs. Budaj edge it's Trump +1 you
see that Trump is strongest in Iowa
against Bernie and Warren +7 against
each of them and then Trump ahead of
Biden by four and Pete Buddha judge the
strongest in Iowa against Trump behind
him by only one point basically a tie
within the margin of error so there's
good news here and there's bad news here
the bad news is that in some states
Trump is doing way better than in those
hypothetical national polls okay that's
not good news if you want to see a
Democrat win but there are lots of
people saying the skies falling over
these Iowa results but you've got to
remember this is Iowa let me remind you
Trump
defeated Hillary Clinton in Iowa by
almost 10 points in 2016 51 to 41 if you
look at the decimals it's about nine and
a half points if Trump wins Iowa but
only by seven or wins Iowa but only by
four that is a worse night for Trump in
Iowa than in 2016 and it could actually
be a signal that things are going to go
against Trump in states that were even
closer so I'm really finding myself
disgusted with the propagandizing cycles
that are happening around polling
polling matters but you need to
understand what we can glean from it
today we are talking about or we talked
about it yesterday rather in terms of
impeachment polls and it's also
important to talk about this here the
headlines are outrageous the headlines
either imply Democrats are dead in the
water because of this poll or sometimes
they make other wild claims you look at
the National hypothetical polls and you
see people say Trump getting crushed by
every Democrat this thing is done Trump
is doing better in Iowa than he's doing
nationally but at the same time Iowa is
a state that he won by 10 in 2016 so if
the baseline is Trump plus 10 he's doing
worse than 2016
right now don't fall for the
disinformation campaign understand what
you can and cannot glean from any
particular poll privacy calm is one of
our sponsors and they're giving you
$5.00 just for using their free service
at privacy comm slash Pakman privacies
of service I've been using for a while
now I love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free and it's
very quick to set up and here's how it
works when you pay for something online
or over the phone instead of exposing
your real credit card number privacy
lets you generate virtual card numbers
the payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend just for signing up when you go
to privacy calm slash Pakman